okay hello everyone welcome to another
Wolfman language design review
uh looking at various items for our
incremental language development
program
all right first up we have file system
tree and file system expression tree
structure
Department
yeah yeah this is for the 13-2 uh review
for trees
okay
so
file system map
would normally has various kinds of
options but just determining the base
directory the depth
and it has like two ways does it not of
showing the results
hierarchical keys in in um
data sets
and something where the inner Keys
aggregate the whole path is that correct
about file system app yeah
yeah there's an optional argument
basically for how you you know there's
both the option an argument for how deep
you go and also an option for how nested
the output should be
um okay but in this case with tree and
we expect that at each node it will just
be a directory name
unless you specify that argument where
you flatten it further
okay but I don't understand this why are
we copying what why is The Edge named
the exact same thing as its destination
well the the the the data of the nodes
is actually the absolute file path
okay but why are we just playing the the
file name oh what
why are we displaying the file name on
the edge redundantly
it seems silly to me
that's what I'm saying it gives Noah new
information does it no I mean
that's completely obscure it says
executables math and then 2948 I don't
understand that what the heck is that
so this was file system map of file byte
count so the leaves are byte counts
oh boy
so right so the intermediate I don't
know the intermediate nodes are
are the names of the directories and the
files are integers
yeah well if this is what we're doing we
should not
label the intermediate nodes they should
just be generic
because otherwise we're going to repeat
you know in other words if we're using
the edges
to um
well the point is The Edge is only one
part of a path
whereas the nodes would already have the
full path control I understand that but
the whole path
it can be read off by going down the
edges right
not conveniently
also you can imagine wanting to do
things where like you extract a sub tree
and you are like you know you find the
sub tree that corresponds with this
directory no I agree I I completely
agree with having the data in the
payloads of those nodes no no but in
order to do that you need to have the
paths in the the data for the for the
intermediate nodes for for the paths
right no if I wanted to find the path
for executables it needs to be labeled
that way it's much harder if you have to
to to infer it from the the edges
no I agree I'm just complaining about
the visual appearance of this thing
having repeated information about the
the directories
that doesn't make sense to me I mean you
know having
a tree that you could then say do tree
map over
I know I'm not I'm saying you've got to
have the data there I'm saying if you're
going to display the tree you cannot
display the thing with repeated
information
transformations
wait is that only by like
by that do you mean that you would take
this and then do something to it and
then it wouldn't be repeated or do you
mean that there's something you can do
in the input like imagine you imagine
you mapped file bite count over the
whole tree
then every node would just be an integer
but you'd still have the same keys
well except the leaves would also be
broken but yeah
well that's because file system map
already maps on the leaves you could
have done identity
but let's zoom out for a second here
okay
um
okay
what are we trying to do here
we have an association
that is quite hierarchical
from which we could make an expression
tree
we want a more convenient tree-like
structure for representing file system
results
right
yes
now
the structure we have up above
I mean what's the alternative thing that
we can do in in file system map that
shows different
um
what's your magic is
um uh you know Keys yeah comma one would
flatten down to a single Association
that has potentially two levels for each
key
okay
so if I go to level three here
and I flattened to level two
okay
so this is so one question is
what the right way to have
um
a tree structure that is formed from
nested associations
what other things do we have that give
nested associations
let me point out
that for the tree itself I see the tree
itself
essentially the association keys are
Port names in the tree is that correct
essentially
so if I were to do a part extraction on
this tree I would part extract by the
path
is that correct
correct
how would I actually do it what do I
actually do I'd say tree extract
yeah copy that tree
then do tree extract
yeah tree extract
of that tree comma
like add-ons
that's true
Ben wolfen desktop so how would I do
that I would say bin
would I say this bin comma
okay
what is that file system Open Bracket I
don't know what that is I'll have to fix
that okay
okay
but so okay so this is quite nice so
this is basically saying
within this tree
something goofed up that but but I mean
within this tree I can extract from a
path
so that path
our file system operations do they
naturally give those paths and lists
in other words if I took if I say
directory
well let's just do installation
directory instead
and they're more interesting
okay so now how do I get that into a
path of the type that I had before
file name split yeah
okay which includes a null one at the
top
okay
I wanna I wonder what this does here
so
right there's a subtle difference in how
the root node is handled between
expression tree and file system tree
so expression tree eats the output of
file system map
so it doesn't have any information about
the actual root directory that you gave
the file system tree has the root
directory in the root node
so
I think we do need to have some
identities between what you get from the
path and what we get from tree extract
of this thing
so we need to think that through
am I making sense
yeah
okay so let's look back at this so what
you're basically doing is you're taking
yeah I mean and this is sorry in terms
of the the default display of this thing
we can presumably determine that kind of
arbitrarily what file system
tree how it displays by default correct
and we can set a bunch of options for
that display yeah
mm-hmm
so one thing we changed and and we have
design here is adding a slight
transparent background on the edge
labels
which helps quite a bit with collisions
yeah
I mean I assume we don't do we know how
to write the edge labels along the edges
that would be a nice feature to have
I don't know if there's a way to do that
foreign
well are you drawing this as a graph
yeah this is using either graph plot or
tree plot for the formatting
but is that what you generically do with
tree
yeah
I think we should look into getting
these things written along the edges
okay it oh
uh
okay well so what else do we have to
figure out here so um file system tree
takes the same arguments presumably as
file system map
is that correct except for the first
argument it doesn't take a function
Demand right right
and and there's an identity between tree
map
and
file system file system map is tree map
of file system tree true statement or
not
except that the data structure that is
returned so so here's a question how do
I convert from the nested associations
to a tree and Back Again
you do expression tree of the nested
associations comma file system and then
convert back yeah but but what about I
just want that's the associations in
general and not specifically let's just
use the streaming Association
the the string what
Association okay
okay
have you used this for anything in
practice has anybody used this for
anything in practice
like if I want to copy
you know if I want to rearrange my file
system tree
is there a realistic way to do it with
is there a way to copy you know trees to
trees and things like that
are you wanting changes to actually be
written to the file system or I don't
know I don't know it's some way to
specify the command but also I'm
wondering in terms of file system tree
whether this kind of tree-like structure
how do I format this to be a side tree
so to speak
Dentistry out
what's that
tree outline
no no I don't mean this I mean this
thing opened
no I don't mean this what what is that
what what's going on there
do you want it with all the openers
already open or
look I'm not sure this is the right
format but I mean I
do you want layout right
let's just see
I just say this what is it called tree
layout right
doesn't look like it
oh left probably
my gosh
kind of intense
yeah why did it go this is just crazy
foreign
this wasn't what I was looking for I
mean what I was looking for was
something
I mean look this is not a good design
for for for what this produces
that
okay
we need a way of getting the I mean
people draw file system trees all the
time and they don't look bad
and they do it using something which is
intermediate between this kind of view
and this kind of view let's figure out
what it is
am I making sense
yep something like a file system
Explorer whatever you would have on a
yeah additional desktop yeah yeah I mean
that's what we want to have here is
something you know there are different
tree views
um
like you can use voice
yeah it's just something in chat which
has an example it's basically the code
that creates the file tree and the
packet resource notebooks
yeah yeah
this is the kind of thing we want
beautiful
they're each individual cells though so
it would still need to be wrapped up
into a single
I understand that has to be redone but I
mean in terms of visual appearance
that's much closer to what we want
I mean this is specifically a file
system play
so we should make it look like and you
know file systems have been around for
50 years and there's lots of development
of how to display things in file systems
in like finders and things like that
right we should make use of that
look in terms of the raw tree structure
I it's probably okay what we've got I
don't exactly know about the treatment
of the root node
but in terms of the visual appearance is
not okay
so
yep yep
so you know I think we need to try and
iterate on that again and try and make
something whose visual appearance
by whatever settings are given is closer
to the kinds of things that that um are
associated with um
um you know typical file browsers
reasonable
yep
all right let's move on from this right
now we're going to have to come back to
this obviously this is a you know this
is a current thing so we've got to solve
this quickly
is there anything else you would like to
get in this meeting about this
I I think in terms of what we do in like
13 2 having something which just
generates the tree is already useful so
long as we're sure that we handle the
root node correctly
am I making sense
I mean is do you want to talk about the
root note have you thought about the
root node
yeah so file system tree
uh it gives
the similar structure except absolute
file paths are used
expression tree gives us relative paths
and that's because it eats a file the
output of file system app which doesn't
preserve the root in its output
okay sorry walk me through this again so
you're saying file system tree does
preserve the root
why not
yes so therefore it's tree extract comes
exactly from file systems file name
split is that correct
no it the
you don't need to do a different part
spec
um like in both cases you would just
take rest of file name split all right
so so you have to use rest to file name
split
in both the file system map example and
the file system tree correct yep okay
well that's life okay
okay
I mean it's interesting that file system
that file name split as that null string
at the beginning it's kind of odd
and I mean it you know it seems
conceivable to me that we should have a
function that doesn't say
you know
file path list or something which just
does the right thing
and then retire family well the path is
going to be ambiguous
I see what you're saying I see what you
say I see I see okay Fair Point yep okay
that's a reasonable point
so in in the case of file name split
you're saying we need to know where it's
anchored and we don't need to know where
it's anchored once it's a free-floating
tree floating down the river so to speak
it doesn't matter where the tree yeah
that right
yeah file name Joy needs the the
trailing blank to reconstruct the
original path
all right anything else we just discuss
with file system tree right now
nope okay let's move on
low hanging fruit
it's kind of broken these up by topic we
can jump around a bit but I've tried to
keep related things together right
um so this is a proposal we had a while
ago uh I did some looking into it I
think there's you know we have some
curation already where data has phonetic
forms but there's lots of variation
um I think you know we need to account
for the different phonetic forms that
are out there yeah tomato and tomato
yeah we also need Locale yeah because
that's it's going to be pronounce
pronounced differently in different
locations and also the method of
representation is different so all of
those are different ways to write
elephants phonetically
so one thing that will be very useful I
would think is that it's a translator
between all those ways
um
yeah I mean even so like the first four
of those are all International Phonetic
Alphabet they're just different locales
pronunciations oh I see I see so that's
actually a different different ways to
say elephant yeah in their historical
ways to say elephant and okay but so the
so the two different axes one is the
different representations like that
might be IPA and that might be some
different phonetic representation yeah
that's usually called hyphenated form or
hyphenated okay all right okay fine so
one thing that will be clearly useful
and rather deterministic function is a
translator between these different
insofar as it can be done between these
different forms I mean it obviously
can't be completely done because this
has less information than this has right
yeah
does this does the last one have as much
information as the as the initial one no
so I IPA is very descriptive
um so the other one that's really
interesting is sampa which is basically
a machine readable form of IPA that uses
ASCII
um it's really difficult to read human
for humans because you get ampersands
and Open brackets as ways of inflecting
positive pronunciation
um but there are so there are
translations from sampa to IPA and to
from IPA to some of the phonetics and
presumably does our speak function work
with any of these things
does a speak function work with IPA
I don't believe it did the last time I
checked but I haven't it may not be
possible I mean I don't know what it
depends how the synthesis works yeah
but okay so it's been trained on you
know glottal fricatives and things yeah
yeah
but so
my question do we have Alan or anybody
else from the the linguistic curation
effort here
uh
we don't at the moment maybe okay so
fine so I mean look the basic Point here
is
um
uh
um
let me see
um
so I guess for me I think there's
there's a couple of degrees of freedom
in either phonetic form or pronunciation
of how you're representing it and how
you are looking up the pronunciation but
look this project has many has has
multiple pieces right it has the audio
piece of you know doing the machine
learning audio analysis to break a piece
of audio into I you know to put turn it
into IPA that's one thing that shoddy's
team has been talking about doing for
ages
okay all right so let's find out about
that that's part number one part number
two
um is
uh
the curation side of okay we've got one
phonetic form for elephant what about
the Irish phonetic form for elephant or
whatever
um
okay yeah
um
I don't know what the state of that
curation is I don't know how realistic
it is I don't know whether we can do
anything on that Etc
the next thing is
a well the next thing which I believe
Alan had made progress on is even just
the curation of phonetic elements like
what's a glottal stop you know what's a
fricative
etc etc etc so in other words turning
elephant into okay tell me how many
fricatives there are in elephant yeah
basically
curating phones and then having method
and place of articulation Associated
yeah yes exactly and being able to make
you know the picture of the the you know
the mouth picture all those kinds of
things
um
so I mean I think this requires a
discussion with Alan and those guys and
Alan and Charlie and you guys and I
think
for you know the the part that is more
pure text manipulation is things like
um
translation between these different
equivalent forms
or translation into the inequivalent
form where you're going where you're
flattening IPA down to something like
this hyphenated form yeah there are some
destructive Transformations and there's
some that don't lose information okay
right
I think that's what we need and and you
know our test case here is how easy is
it to write a Rhymer
um
because it should be easy if we've done
this correctly
yeah
yeah that's certainly a good application
example to look at
well actually we've got I've got two
examples there I've got that and I've
got prosody stuff right like so so you
know can you scan a sentence and tell me
where the short and long
uh
what other else I guess oh yeah
we should be able to do that if we if we
can turn it into fanatic form we should
be able to do that and and we should be
able to have the um uh you know we
should be able to go all the way from
the audio
to a marked up phonetic form
um
right I mean this is something we've
been working towards for ages I think we
should also check that the things we're
doing really cover the things that like
people do in phonetics classes and stuff
like this
okay yeah yeah I mean that's enough of
my old Linguistics uh textbook when I
was looking at this definitely there is
some overlap there
yeah
yeah we need to be able to do you know I
don't know I mean I've got some
textbooks on my hair about Fanatics so
we need to just be able to you know do
all everything that's in there
we should be able to
yeah I will check in with the relevant
parties and we'll see if we can get a
status update for everything together
okay let's talk about this type of thing
we have a family of functions and this
is really for the that
that are essentially
canonic canonicalization of English
functions
okay another one which we're going to
need is enough a resolution you know
uh
the cat
ate the fish
and she was not happy however you
resolved that one because you don't know
yeah right but but
um
uh
you know
the
I'm gonna I'm gonna make up other ones
that don't work and in modern times you
know pronoun resolution has become even
much more difficult
um but uh
um
basic point is
um
uh to
you know we're going to you know
basically take a piece of English
and make it as canonical as possible
that is
resolve the pronouns
removal contractions
Etc
yeah this is an important precursor to
some of the things we want to do with
symbolic symbolicization
of the language
but I you know to me that's that's a
goal this is this is one part of that
canonicalization story okay
yeah I mean this is so the example I
have here is basically just a a
low-tech toy implementation of static
replacement and the immediate thing I
ran into when looking at it is that you
a lot of English contractions have
ambiguity in terms of tenses and
conjugation yeah and well but that so it
means it has to be more sophisticated it
has to actually do things like the
pronoun resolution yep so I was thinking
there's either some ml or some other
like also more talk to the ml
group and but I mean in general the goal
has to be this kind of
I mean there's a there's a well-known
set in computational linguistics of
these kinds of operations like the
pronoun resolution thing there's like
four of them or something I mean I think
it's not a huge number
let's try and figure out what we go do
to get towards implementing those okay
yeah I think it it's helpful which is
going to have some kind of machine
learning entanglement okay
okay
so this is a topic from a while ago it
is the notion of so we have time off
August 4th yeah August 4th how do we
represent that there are various ways
that we've tried to do that in the past
um you know there's an internal
scheduling notation for things like
scheduled tasks
and
I mean does it have blank eight four
because that will be the obvious thing
to do
yes and there are limitations with that
because positional arguments only get
you so far immediately if you're looking
yeah I know first Monday yep first
Monday third you know second
Tuesday of the month or first Tuesday
that is not the first of the month
things like that get complicated we have
a market oh sorry go ahead no sorry go
finish for yourself we we have an
attempt at more sophisticated language
and date select which we added a few
versions ago which lets you
create a criteria based on various
different date patterns and we try and
do some intelligent things to
compile those down so that we're doing
things a little more efficiently but
there's not a way to represent a date
object that's just a date selection
group I'm sorry I I got a comment on the
fact that this stupid raft keeps on
running away again
you know you try and click on it and it
disappears yeah yeah I just okay anyway
date select
so the the second argument is basically
criteria that we have
put together and you can combine any
number of things which is very
expressive but it gets complicated
quickly
and yeah but on the other hand you can I
mean many of those criteria are in fact
quite complicated yes
so like I think there's an example under
applications for U.S presidential
elections are
right so just out of curiosity though I
mean do we have already a great example
you know date date objects that
represent kind of many moments in time
like discontiguous moments in time
because we already have granularities
but saying something like you know
January 1st does that mean January 1st
of every year or does that mean some
sort of unresolved January 1st and if
you run absolute time on it it will say
failed or something like that we we do
not currently all data objects need to
be resolvable to a single instant
so I mean what Christopher is implicitly
suggesting is there could be some
periodic granularity
um
I'm not sure about well maybe maybe that
but I was gonna say I'm not sure it's
the same thing as a granularity no I
don't because the point is a granularity
you can also turn into an instant I mean
the question is you know maybe this is a
different head it's not date object
yeah I mean what we we talked about
something like date pattern would be
useful but date patterns already taken
and is something like in regular
expression date pattern
but the idea of being able to say this
is not a single date instant but it is
some representation of either a generic
date or recurring date or a schedule
notation
[Music]
so I mean depending on what what exactly
the specification for this would be
could it also be some kind of symbolic
date select or something like that yeah
I mean I think that's what you'd
ultimately want to do with you know we
kind of sort of can get there by doing
date select on a date interval with some
criteria inside it so you don't
explicitly have to generate the range
but it still is ultimately spitting back
out a definite set of dates and
what you want for things like when
meteor showers occur they occur on a
semi-regular basis we want to be able to
return that in the language and have
some representation that says this is
the pattern of date events or this is
the schedule at which this happens well
wait a minute is it one concept or two I
mean so August 4th
disembodied year
[Music]
is that the same concept as the
repeating event that occurs every August
4th
it's not obvious to me it depends on
context in that that is kind of one of
the tripping points there is do we
separate those out as you know this is
we should I think we should say August
4th or this is a August 4th no I think I
think we should separate them I think we
should have a thing which is is a
generic pattern
that matches any August 4th hmm
and then we should have something that
affirmatively says
the groundhog comes out on this day
every year
I think in other words I don't think
it's the same thing I think one is a
pattern and the other is a recurring
event a periodic event
just like granularity gives you a a
contiguous event
so the distinction is one of them is
just ambiguous it's like you don't know
which August 4th versus every other
sport
right and if you say does it match that
you can answer that question if you say
make it happen on that debt or you could
say when's the next one of these
yeah you see that's the point that's the
point when's the next one of these with
a pattern makes perfect sense
if the you know if the if the groundhog
wherever the heck it is it's coming out
every every year at the same date which
I don't think they do I think at some of
the point
um the uh
then saying what's the next one well you
could say what's the next one of that
sequence I suppose but the sequence goes
on forever
I don't know that wasn't very well
described
okay so so the first question is the
generic August 4th
[Music]
so okay date select is taking a
pre-existing
sort of date soup
and it's pushing out of it a definite
set of dates
as specified one way or another
right as opposed to allowing it to go
into a trillion ID
right
um
it's tough to know quite what months are
supposed to do a billion years from now
when the orbit of the moon has changed
and so on anyway never mind we're not
going there
um
uh
well let's see
hmm
I mean I think this is a worthwhile
thing for us to explore I'm not sure
that we're
yeah so we've got we got the
the thing we have currently called Date
pattern unfortunately is something
different
[Music]
um
date schedule or schedule object
that's possible for the one that is that
represents the repeating thing right
I mean we could also just call it
repeating date object
or a date array like quantity array no
because that's that's a that's yeah
that's a concept that actually has
repeated things in it
well okay but let's look at these two
concepts
one is
a
concept that could in fact be part of
data object that is just this thing that
has omitted
I mean look the difference between time
object and date object time object is a
generic sized date object at some level
it contains headless
well it's it's anchor it's anchor
pointless it's yeah it's
and what we're saying here is we want
something that's between time object and
data object that has you know day month
but no year for example
and then we also want
something that allows the criteria of
date select
where you have an object that you can do
things with like say what's the next one
of these
um right so we want a an implicit date
selection I don't think it's bad to go
straight from
a pure blank an element of data object
to the date select logic
I think people will be just happy that
they can specify the third Monday when
it isn't a leap year type thing
you know and I don't think it's that
hard to use that specification I think
any other specification
that starts getting ornate with first
Mondays is going to be a big mess
therefore what I think we need is
something which is okay I think we need
two things we need a thing where you can
just give a pattern and we need
something that represents I mean in
other words represents well that's to
say generic date object for now
um
but it might be able to be put into Data
object itself but I mean let's say
generic data object it could be
something like you know blank eight four
or it could be something that says
um and the syntax isn't right but you
know hash
day name
equals Monday
or something
um
okay and then for this we need what's
the way of getting the next instance of
something uh next state
or date plus potentially but yeah okay
the next date so what's the next how do
I get the next instance of what's a
what's a thing I could get the next you
could say Monday on there actually and
you get the next Monday you guys
Assemble
okay and what happens if I want the next
first day of the month
uh I you might be able to do beginning
of month as a string I'm not sure if
that one's gonna work
okay but but what we want in the end is
next date of generic date object of I
mean in that particular case the first
of the month I would want something like
um this thing blank blank one yep
which should be quite civilized really
um
so I mean it's just these two
possibilities it seems to me either
blanks or
I mean these blanks could even have
conditions in them I mean it could be x
blank slash semi whatever
yeah yeah
okay
I mean also you know maybe there's a way
to do this
where this thing is essentially a slash
semicondition
I'm not sure because I mean we've got
this day name it's kind of like an
association
I'm not sure but this is what we need we
need we need something which has those
two things and to my mind if we had this
if we had this sort of generic date
object we can have something that then
represents the periodic thing
right then we could have something that
says All Dates between this time and
this time that match this pattern get me
all dates that match this pattern
between this and this hmm
should we use perhaps all instead of
blank
yeah I think there's a question between
all or any or
automatic or none well the nice thing
about blank is we could actually use the
pattern language and we could do things
like I I really favor using the pattern
language because I mean if we say the
first or the 15th of the month it's very
beautiful well the the plus of that is
that it's easy to write the problem is
that you know then they're going to be
weird cases that you can't really
support like you know you're gonna have
things like uh you know you're gonna
have the day you know question mark
Prime cue or something and I don't know
you know it becomes so floppy I'm not
sure but I don't see why we can't do
that I mean worst case is you enumerate
all the dates in the range and you see
which ones match
I I really strongly believe we should
use the pattern language for this I
think it's going to be very nice and in
worst case is you know there's some
things we can't compile and in those
things we have to do exhaustive search
basically to figure out what matches
but imagine returning these objects so
potentially we can have these objects on
the right hand side
of functions and things like that
and then there will be messages
complaining that we have patterns on the
right hand side
or imagine these things in in keys of
associations
so I'm worried that we are going to have
interactions between patterns and other
functions that are not expecting
patterns
I think that the value of having this as
a pattern is really high
I think we should figure out whether
that's going to happen I I really think
we should do this because I mean how
would you do this otherwise you'd have
to have some weird notation that you
have to look up
whereas if you if we just do it with
patterns everybody knows how to do this
I I understand the value I I'm just
worried that we usually don't use
patterns to represent actual objects we
use patterns for pattern many functions
and things like that I know I know so
it's a slight generalization I think we
should try it I think we should try
figuring out whether we make this work
now I mean I think that also
I'm a little concerned about the natural
way to have the you know the function
uh selection mechanism
see I mean
it's like either you have an as if
Association
or you have
an
a thing that's matching the pattern
I mean and maybe they should be
different heads
I mean and one could be
I wish we could use date pattern but uh
and we maybe should look at what date
pattern really does
um
I mean if one was date Criterion and one
was date pattern or something or date
test
that's kind of silly but um
uh anyway look I think we have a path
here
um and I think then you know again we've
got to have a resolver that says given
the generic
tell me everything that matches that
within a particular interval
that's probably the most important thing
um
because I mean you know knowing it for
the infinite future a million years from
now is kind of irrelevant
this is effectively what they select us
no yeah on a date interval or something
like that can you do like a relative
computations between them how long is it
from a September 3rd to a September 12th
hmm
yeah that's an interesting question
I mean that's essentially regions in
what we're getting is it's sort of a
temporal logic-ish type thing
that's a good question
right the the minimum distance from one
generic object to another
all right several things to look at here
let's keep going but this is clearly a
worthwhile thing to pursue okay
we never did this did we
no I mean we have we had a notion of it
but the
I mean we can emulate what mod does for
dates where we can basically say you
know we want a a Max bin size or a
offset
but how useful is it and is it kind of
an intermediate step trying to get
something else we want so like date
histogram list the next item is another
case where
it's tied closely to generic dates or
date reduction so date reduction is the
option in date histogram that does what
date mod would do but you don't actually
see the output dates you just see the
results in visualization
I want it compressed over well here's an
example
um I have all my
data on when
um
you know when the squirrel went up the
tree
and it's you know
but I want to make a diurnal plot that
shows
you know when
you know what time of the morning did
the squirrel go and collect its nut so
to speak that type of thing is that what
this is for
in other words it's for folding things
into like mod does it folds into a
particular sub-region right yeah it's
you know it's somewhat analogous to like
the time series operations of of
rescaling or windowing but we have all
this data that covers whatever period
and we want it to be well actually you
know what this this operation should be
done for time series as well you should
be able to fold a Time series and say I
want to take this time series and I want
all the points in other words let's say
you have a few scattered points
that show
you know of some process that's supposed
to be the same every day
but you have scattered points that show
that you measured it at different times
each day you measured it three or four
times a day and you want to fold them
all together how do you do that
that's what I'm saying so I mean it's
basically taking the base states
and I agree that this is a useful
operation I wanted to do this a bunch of
times
and this kind of date reduces more than
anything else
I would have thought yeah it's a it's a
folding things into
a particular granularity like it's it's
a give this to that granularity
just like it's mod 2 or something give
this to this granularity and throw away
anything but but in order to represent
things at that granularity because dates
are you know absolutely anchored absent
a generic date I'm not quite sure how we
do that
in other words you know when we reduce I
mean I suppose with Mod 7 or something
we are reducing to the canonical value
zero through six we don't have to have
those clinical values
and so we could just have a point of
view but I'm not sure to into onto which
generic date
you know that would be the third
argument of date mode like model yes the
reference State effectively
I see
of course this would also relate to the
previous discussion we could reduce by
just removing the year and inserting a
blank indeed
right yeah I think all of these all
three of these topics are sort of tied
together which is why it's been hard to
to iron any individual one out is there
tendrils that touch on a lot of things
right
well I mean clearly okay
we need a generic date
that doesn't that's not anchored by
and the question is does the generic
date simply blank out
one of the elements of a date object or
can it be more elaborate than that
because in the modding business we're
simply granularizing I mean you know
could we reduce mod 10 days in the
whatever it was you know the the French
Revolutionary calendar or whatever no
maybe they had hours maybe they messed
with hours I don't remember but you know
somebody has invented the 10-day week
um they had it in different religion yes
okay fine the um
okay so that calendar in the language
too you'd say what is today on the
French Revolutionary calendar how long
did it last in reality like three years
or something two years
seven maybe oh really
um
people didn't like weeks of 10 days if
they only had one holiday
right
right it lasted one robes beer
right the oh was that a unit even
um no that's a joke
um
okay
um
so okay but so we're not seriously
imagining that we reduce mod 10 days
is that correct we we only think we're
reducing mod actual granularities that
we've defined
no I think with date mode if we have in
the second argument quantity 10 days
we could simply compute days
we have no generic representation of a
10-day repeating thing
no no but I I'm I mean this function was
thought not for the genetic case but
just to compute
um particular new dates
for example imagine that you have all
the dates of Easter in many many years
you can reduce them to the same year and
compare them
well except that it's kind of a hack to
reduce them to the same year because
they don't in fact I mean let me point
out let me give you an example of why
that will fail what about leap years you
reduce them to the same year and oops
one of them has a February 29th
what do you do
well but
I mean the usefulness of this for
example is then to plot them all
together with data list plot no I
understand it's not going to show the
year
no I understand but I'm saying the
following I'm saying I consider it a
hack
to do the reduction all to 1900 let's
say
okay I I understand that but this is an
operation that we have for numbers
already in mode
so I think it would be nice to have it
also for dates just imitating what do we
do for numbers no I understand but the
point is that the number okay here's my
point it is not the case that
a canonical mod
block so to speak zero to six let's say
because
the integers
have this sort of translation variance
property
we don't have the problem that you might
land you know your reduced
block
could be a year that has no February
29th
yet you had a February 29th and you're
trying to reduce it into that year that
has no February 29th what do you do
here
what do we do do we turn an error
message in that case or what
no no I mean we put them in the in the
if you have selected a day a year with a
leap year then and we get 10 consecutive
days and one of them is a little year so
it
that's what you selected
so you have to specify the third
argument in which you just specify the
date you want to start with
I understand but I'm saying I'm I'm
confused if if what you are reducing is
a February 29th and your destination
year has no February 29th what do you do
but it depends producing how you are
reducing for example you say the second
argument is is you're reduced by 100 100
days
no I mean okay okay so what you're
saying is
just like we have that roll over role
whatever it is that whole business yeah
that basically the mod would have a
similar rolling property exactly yeah
This is complicated
arithmetic usually is it's really easy
for machines and it mapping anything
onto the ways that people actually use
time is always complicated
right
okay well in any case so so then
you're saying date reduce
would reduce
a date
by
a repetition interval
onto a certain Target
right that's the basic operation
yes
okay
if it had no Target
the nice thing and we had generic dates
the obvious thing to do would be for it
to reduce it onto a generic date
right
now the question is I mean I really
think we need generic dates
and the only question is do we need
generic dates that just
leave blanks where we could put an all
or a none in there
I think days of the week are the big
thing that are missing there yeah
we have symbols for days of the week but
we don't have a way to tie them in
really well I mean they you could we
don't have a first Monday wave we don't
know where to represent first Monday we
have a way to represent Monday yeah
um
I I can do a little more yeah why don't
you think about this more to put this
together and we'll look at some specific
examples in another meeting
uh by the way
Dan commented on that live stream
earlier in connection with the file
system thing that it would be nice to
have a button to open the file
from the study structure I agree
if we're going to display the thing in
some fancy way we might as well have a
open this file button
right I think that Rick's little
implementation has that already
okay
all right let's look quickly at this
find Astro events as part yeah well
finding scissories
presumably we'll eventually get that
presumably we can find suzages to our
ephemorities provide scissors
um not directly but but if the plan is
to have some sort of fine Master event
function in which you specify the type
of event you want and the interval you
are interested in
okay and it will find so find closest
approaches of Mars and Jupiter or
something exactly so these are very
large variety of these events that are
interesting in astronomy
yeah I mean we might need to have some
language to represent that event exactly
yeah
I don't know
I mean they have all of these things you
know
when I mean they have names for all
these things you know and opposition in
and whatever yeah so that's probably
what we need to do is catalog those
names and start thinking about what so
in other words is it the case that most
of the time it is a name blah a it's a
two argument function
blah is in opposition to blar or
something is that is that the typical
type of thing
I I think so a name and then arguments
there may be the closest approach
between these two
right it's mostly two body object things
well I mean there's weird cases like
like
you know when does the when is The Grand
Tour possible with the planets
that you can go and align and basically
get meet every planet when it comes
there in its orbit type thing
yes I'm not sure about the number of
arguments there might be cases in which
we need quite a few specific access and
oh axes oh gosh yes
hmm
yeah right
okay uh
all right let's just take a look at
these
so this is related to Christopher's
project of video raster and how to get
information
well I think we we all agree that we
really want you know gridded population
vegetation indices all these kinds of
things that will be extremely useful to
have
as a standardized thing I think you know
we're just planning on that I don't know
what the right name for it is
are there supposed to be data functions
like country data like they get data or
is that yes definitely I think they get
name data will curate 50 different types
of you know things about the world that
you might get
all in this kind of you know scalar
value type form
I mean I could imagine generalizing it
to Vector values for winds and things
like this but but in first approximation
there will be scalar values with dates
saying you know ocean temperature as a
function of whatever or
you know I don't know what carbon
dioxide level as a function of whatever
and so something like geomapping data
would be like get me this census tract
or something like that
uh well I assume these are mostly image
related I mean these are mostly Vector
you know scale of fields as a function
of geoposition
we have the president for example of of
geographic model data that reports
vectors too
we have additional field all the
magnetic fields yes yes yes yes yes I
see so okay so what Christopher is
asking something more like geo-gravity
data that gets richer data that could be
numerical data not like from a census
tract for example rather than what I was
imagining which is sort of big swaths of
image data
these are two maybe these are these are
definitely two different things but one
of them is right I think we're using
Vector both to mean Vector fields and
vectors in like a polygon right so like
a you know I mean right now though we
have ways of doing the polygon case just
through entities so that's probably the
way to do it that's what I was going to
complain about so yeah yeah right but
what we don't have is
given this region of the earth I just
want to see the the
I don't know the type of rock or
something as a as a bitmap
well did we kind of do through Geo image
right like if you had lots of Geo
servers and so on you could kind of do
through geometry but the problem is that
there's also stuff like like you know as
I was mentioning Vector valued
images or rasters
although we could hack that with
different color you know with a
um no they also got hyperspectral on
things as well so I mean the the
question of what the representation you
know whether the hyperspectral stack
represents elements of a you know Vector
space so what kind of a vector space it
is seems like it's a second order issue
because I can imagine some weird
you know
uh weird geometry which I don't think
we're going to deal with and as far as
we're concerned it's just a bunch of
components
but I think what's an important
we have your vector to describe those
things and for example wind data can't
return to your vector objects and there
are arrays of them fair enough but I
mean then but
but there's also this whole question
about projections and this whole issue
about I want to measure how much Granite
there is in this area well I need to
know what projection it is otherwise I'm
going to think Greenland is just full of
granite or whatever right
um and that relates to our discussion
about Geo raster and the whole
projection issue which we have to come
back to okay
yeah
these things are doable I I think the
difficult part here is getting the data
is it I mean I thought NASA had this
whole Blue Marble
data set it was just
Oodles of these things
there is data out there but I mean in
general it may not be
um Global or we will have to I think
there is a bunch of low resolution
global data that's readily available for
50 different properties
right the the only problem is that well
they're like
at least yeah at least like the NASA
sites they have they have a pretty good
API if you just want you know colorful
images if you know what I mean like
images where they'll say something like
you know oh this shows uh you know land
temperature on a scale of purple to
orange or something which isn't very
useful
um if you want to get the actual raw
data they have
there are some apis but but from what I
can tell they're kind of complicated and
they're very like you submit a job and
then it gets completed a few minutes
later and stuff like this where it's not
fair so we'll have to catch a bunch of
these things
maybe yeah although I I think we don't I
mean there's like absurd amounts of you
know it was like you know
100 gigabytes a day kind of things so
but right right but anyway this is
something we need to explore because I
think it's definitely super useful
um
Geo Rectify that has to do with camera
stuff right that has to do with an image
that has to do with the projection
something that we don't have which is
reprojecting I mean we have perspective
transmissions and images don't we
we have image transform
so maybe we already have this if we had
a name transform of some kind you know
what I'm talking about that that
photographs taken from a plane of a
random City look weird because all the
tall buildings are distorted yep
um I don't
there's two for also from a satellite or
is that irrelevant by the time you're
that far away
it's fairly irrelevant at the distance
of kilometers aerial photographs that
one used to get before
one got
um
uh
so I don't know whether this is I mean
to me this is a wfr function that
somebody should write that uses image
transform
to you know Rectify those images
and that's about it and it's probably a
dying story well maybe it isn't because
of drone photography I don't know
anybody know
I mean you know because satellite
imagery is becoming so easy to get
and you know probably doesn't have this
issue
look at that Astro Graphics we don't
even have to open that twisty
yep we just went a little Victory lap
that this has been on there for a number
of years and it's done so well it's not
a rate it's almost done it's 4 13 2 yeah
yes
um
wow how much is the yeah
all right just for a couple minutes here
action object yeah this is a big story
yeah so I I we talked with Bob really
briefly about it and we weren't entirely
sure what the difference between an
action object and a task object is
well an action object was a completely
different idea that has to do with um
that had to do
um
yeah that was a Linguistics thing
that we never implemented
that was for like intelligent assistant
actions
that was a way of representing
you know just like we have entities and
and by the way this is something should
come back in the symbolic Discord
language business
that I'd forgotten this thing it's
useful and should be fed to I guess
Johanna Michael trotting people like
that are going to be involved in that
um it's just a way of representing this
kind of verb construct
I see interesting so it has it has
nothing to do with triggered task
basically okay yeah completely separate
story
I'm helpful to know trigger task is
basically and this is something I mean
there's a big push from our blockchain
uh effort to get real-time data feeds
and they are going to want triggered
tasks
finally
which basically say when something
changes in in a central database trigger
on it in some way
you know and this is I mean somehow this
is somewhat related to
uh
yeah I mean yes it's this type of thing
it's it's when something changed okay so
there's poll times and there's push
notifications basically
I try the polling to see whether
something changed which is already quite
useful I mean that that pattern of did
this web page change or something pull
every half hour or something and see
what happened that's already quite
useful
really makes sense yeah which could be a
thin convenience function on top of the
scheduled test
yes it could yes it could I mean so long
as we think that we can maintain them
and not blow out of scheduled task slots
I think that's fine right on the public
Cloud the scheduling is pretty
constrained for good reason I think
we can't go to every minute or anything
like that
right but I agree that having some wfr
functions that do this kind of triggered
you know trigger change change detection
would be a good place to start
but I think the more interesting and
non-trivial thing which we have
discussed for ages is being able to set
triggers that trigger on our internal
databases changing that is we have
you know and I'm not sure what the right
architecture for that is and it would be
a Thing Worth looking at that is you
know we've got feeds coming in of
earthquake feeds and so on you know
trigger if there's ever an earthquake in
England for example which they haven't
lived for a long time I think
um but you know trigger if there's ever
an earthquake more than magnitude 5 in
such and such a place
now the question is how would we do that
how would we set that up because we
don't want to have some bizarre you know
encrustment of our
you know that that every time we add
data I mean what I have believed is that
there's some sort of ticker tape that we
generate and that people can set up
watches that deal with that
anyway I mean I think look let's start
off with this polled you know poll tests
that seems like a good place to start
all right I think we need to wrap up for
today
um this is a good list let's um
uh
well some of these things we've also
done
um
yeah good list and um
time to wrap up for today
all right thanks guys see you all soon